stop conflating communism and democratic
socialism because it's unfair and
inaccurate said the person who
supportively sent me this Karl Marx
video on YouTube rebuttal time you
bearded fat this one's by popular
request because this Karl Marx video is
a little old but has enjoyed a second
win specifically due to the Bernie
Sanders supporters as you will see in
the comments section despite the fact I
swear up and down socialism and
communism have nothing to do with each
other let's get to it most people agree
that we need to improve our economic
systems somehow
yet we're also often keen to dismiss the
ideas of capitalism's most famous and
ambitious critic Karl Marx straumann
nobody dismisses him everybody who's
read Karl Marx and understands economics
doesn't like him they're not dismissing
him they're listening to him saying oh
you're an insane person and deciding to
go the other direction this isn't very
surprising in practice his political and
economic ideas have been used to design
disastrously planned economies and nasty
dictatorships nevertheless
we shouldn't reject Marx too quickly we
ought to see him as a guide whose
diagnosis of capitalism's ills helps us
to navigate towards a more promising
future
capitalism is going to have to be
reformed and Marx's analyses are going
to be part of any answer before we get
some details here it's really important
this person is trying to present this as
unbiased but they're telling you that
you ought to and should look to Karl
Marx as a guide they also say it has
maybe been used for some bad regimes
okay let's flip that nay me any good
communist economies that have company
one let's start with one Marx was born
in 1818 in Trier in Germany soon he
became involved with the Communist Party
a tiny group of intellectuals advocating
for the overthrow of the class system
and the abolition of private property
first up how does anyone watch this
hear that and not literally soil
themselves abolition of private property
the thing you're watching this huh it's
not yours belongs to this bearded guy he
worked as a journalist and had to flee
Germany eventually settling in London
Marx wrote an enormous number of books
and articles sometimes with his friend
Friedrich Engels also approach button
work is alienated one of Marx's greatest
insights is that work can be one of the
sources of our greatest joys
but in order to be fulfilled at work
Marx wrote that workers need to see
themselves in the objects they have
created think of the person who built
this chair it's straightforward strong
honest and elegant it's an example of
how at its best labour offers us a
chance to externalize what's good inside
us right off the bat let's break this
down using their example simple one a
chair it was made by workers that feels
good
you made a chair but what does it not
account for innovation creativity risk
advancement progress this is Ryan I'll
prove this as a recurring theme outside
of some weapons created by government no
communist regimes or countries have been
at the forefront of giant leaps in
technology or innovation those gifts
have never been given to the world
through communism part of the problem is
that modern work is incredibly
specialized specialized jobs make the
modern economy highly efficient but they
also mean that it's seldom possible for
any one worker to derive a sense of the
genuine contribution they might be
making to the real needs of humanity
Marx argued that modern work leads to
alienation and femdom in other words a
feeling of disconnection between what
you do all day and who you feel you
really are and what you think you'd
ideally be able to contribute to
existence here's the crux of Marxism
Karl Marx and people who forward this
focus entirely on the worker
specifically the labor worker here's the
thing the labor worker is not a synonym
for humanity humanity as a whole also
needs medicine progress and efficiency
agricultural innovation needs for
Humanity that cannot be met if the mere
labor workers importance is placed above
all else and work is insecure capitalism
makes the human being utterly expendable
just one factor among others in the
forces of production and one that can
ruthlessly be let go the minute costs
rise or savings can be made through
technology here's where the word play is
so important from the unbelievably
biased presenter they've now referred to
workers as utterly expendable under a
capitalist system in a free enterprise
system your value is determined
precisely by you're contributing power
your skill sets and your work ethic
you're the best engineer in the world
you're pays you're worth under communist
you're not your contribution is worth
the exact same as the guy next to you on
the factory line who has no interest in
contributing at all I just stare at my
desk but it looks like I'm working
so while jobs may be legally barred from
being deemed dispensable guess what
everything that makes you uniquely
valuable as a human being is it's
entirely dispensable you're a number yet
as Marx knew deep inside each of us we
don't want to be arbitrarily let go with
terrified of being abandoned communism
isn't just an economic theory understood
emotionally it expresses a deep-seated
longing that we always have a place in
the world's heart that we will not be
cast out I will see that sounds nice
right place in the world's hearts but
what he just expressed is exactly why
communism lends itself to mass murdering
authoritarian regimes so perfect you
will pay you can only prey on fear and
insecurity can capitalism sure but it
can only work if it simultaneously
highlights the human desire to succeed
to progress and to grow communism can
only even be attempted with a scared and
broken people capitalism free enterprise
is most effectively embraced by
optimistic ones workers get paid little
while capitalists get rich this is
perhaps the most obvious qualms that
Marx had with capitalism in particular
he believes that capitalists shrink the
wages of the laborers as much as
possible in order to skim off a wide
profit margin he called this primitive
accumulation of shmulik accumulate Jean
whereas capitalists see profit as a
reward for ingenuity and technological
talent Marx was far more damning profit
is simply theft and what you're stealing
is the talent and hard work of your
workforce so Karl Marx thinks that
profit is theft you know but he doesn't
think it's theft actual theft I got
robbed by a sweet old lady on a
motorized cart you fancy it
good example I invent the light bulb I
have toiled away creating thousands of
failed prototypes investing some of the
best years of my life while other people
ate slept and enjoy
maybe we spent a little too much time
picking off balconies we had fun huh
finally I create a successful one and it
improves and saves billions of lives
across the world all because of an
ingenious idea and work ethic people
across the world are willing to pay for
my wonderful invention and so I become
wealthy that's capitalism
according to Marxists that's theft same
situation I invent the light bulb only
government comes in and takes all of my
profit at gunpoint
according to Marxists that's not theft
are you getting it yet that's what
communism is and yes even socialism
which is why all of the Bernie
supporters can be found under this video
liking it like it's hot at the end of
the day it comes down to men with guns
forcing you to give them your stuff be a
good little fella now and open the door
so you wonder why not only communism
lends itself to authoritarian regimes
but why leftism lends itself to more
violent disruptive protests like black
lives matter or Occupy Wall Street it's
because despite what hippies and
Democratic socialists tell you at its
core communism and socialism through its
only available methods of collection and
distribution are predicated on the use
of violent force true capitalism and
free enterprise require voluntary
transactions communism and socialism
require coercion you will get off cut
out Karl Marx crises are endemic to
capitalism and they're caused by
something rather odd the fact that we're
able to produce too much far more than
anyone needs to consume capitalist
crises are crises of abundance rather
than as in the past crises of shortage
interesting that Karl Marx brought up
shortages in the past because after
people followed his philosophy these
governments created the greatest
shortages the modern world had ever seen
in communist countries but that's not
necessarily a bad thing sometimes
American journalists talk about how bad
because people are lining up the food
that's a good thing you go you
democratic socialists you I like this
guy now what do you said here is true it
is absolutely true most problems in a
capitalist society are caused by that of
overabundance for example we have an
obesity problem here in the United
States we have such unfettered access to
the widest variety of food the world has
ever seen that yeah some people can
choose to be fat and it's an annoying
problem the United States it results in
broken scales tight airplane seat
squeezes and Lena Dunham in communist
Russia China Cuba North Korea they have
bread lines take your pack
none shall interfere do as you please
our factories and systems are so
efficient we could give everyone in this
planet a car a house access to a decent
school in a hospital and that's what so
enraged Marx but also made him so
hopeful too few of us actually need to
work because the modern economy is so
productive and how did those factories
and hospitals become so efficient giving
away all of this stuff as Karl Marx
wants to do through communism or
socialism requires that it be done on
the back of capitalism again this
channel wants you to believe that it's
presenting its information is factual
and not propaganda which is important
because this isn't a factual argument
but a moral one but rather than seeing
this need not to work as the freedom it
is we complain about it masochistic
Allah and describe it by a pejorative
word unemployment we should call it
freedom there's so much unemployment for
a good and deeply admirable reason
because we're so good at making things
efficiently we're not all needed at the
coalface
but in that case we shoot thought Marx
make leisure admirable we should
redistribute the wealth of the massive
corporations that make so much surplus
money and give it to everyone this is in
its own way as beautiful a dream as
Jesus's promise of heaven but a good
deal more realistic sounding if you
believe it's the government's job to
encourage unemployment and leisure in
place of productivity and innovation
well you know that's just like
your opinion man by the way while we're
comparing leisure which vacation would
you rather take
silly communists I guess it depends the
most leisurely activity Russians ever
engaged in was defecting you about ready
to get maced oh my god don't you get is
that day capitalism is bad for
capitalists Marx didn't think that
capitalists were evil for example he was
acutely aware of the sorrows and secret
Agony's that lay behind bourgeois
marriage Marx argued that marriage was
actually an extension of business and
that the bourgeois family was fraught
with tension oppression and resentment
with people staying together not for
love but for financial reasons Marx
believed that the capitalist system
forces everyone to put the economic
interests at the heart of their lives so
that they can no longer know deep honest
relationships
he called this psychological tendency
commodity fetishism bargain fetish
useless because it makes us value things
that have no objective value he wanted
people to be freed from financial
constraint so that they could at last
start to make sensible healthy choices
in their relationships see this is
interesting because a lot of people
don't realize just how anti-marriage and
traditional family karl marx was granted
yes marriage is one of the greatest
indicators we have of economic stability
wealth and growth it's also the biggest
indicator we have available for health
longevity and personal happiness here's
where contrast is so important whereas
Karl Marx sought to destroy the
traditional family the founding fathers
in the United States were emphatic about
it being the central building block to
the American Way of life why because
before a municipal state or federal
government you had a moral level of
self-governance within the family one
that led to a happier and as karl marx
has pointed out more financially
productive society and that's why many
of our marriage laws exist in the books
to begin with the 20th century feminist
answer to the oppression of women has
been to argue that women should simply
be able to go out to work but Marx's
answer was more subtle this feminist
insistence merely perpetuates human
slavery the point isn't that women
should imitate the sufferings of their
male colleagues it's that men and women
should have the permanent option to
enjoy leisure and this is why modern
social justice warriors like feminists
are so far to the left is there anything
more
to troglodytes liked Wrigley puff than
not getting married which wasn't gonna
happen anyway claiming that you're a
strong woman while not working Karl Marx
was creating his fan base early in short
one of the biggest evils of capitalism
is not that there are corrupt people at
the top this is true in any human
hierarchy but that capitalist ideas
teach all of us to be anxious
competitive conformist and politically
complacent this is key we'll get to the
philosophy in a second but I love how he
skimmed over corruption at the top is
seen in any hierarchy it's a valid point
and one that unravels Karl Marx's
central argument sure in capitalism or
free enterprise there are no doubt some
corrupt people at the top in a true free
enterprise system that corruption is
mitigated by the concept of competition
now invariably when that corruption does
occur repeatedly and systematically as
you see with big banks big energy big
unions that can only do so when abetted
by big government big banks are able to
continually be corrupt why not because
of capitalism but because of a
never-ending supply of big bailout funds
from equally corrupt politicians now at
least you can still choose to use a
local bank or credit union who never
required bailouts to begin with but
let's change the scenario the big
corrupt government you and I both hate
for bailing out big banks now it is the
bank it is your only bank it is also
your only grocery store your only phone
provider your only health insurance
that's communism as seen with every
communist regime ever it leads to
massive death and totalitarianism every
time so if this man and Karl Marx
acknowledged that in any hierarchy you
will find corruption at the top why oh
why would you want to hand over that top
to a centralized government monopoly
where no voluntary transactions are even
necessary only the use of violent
coercion Marx was not a well-regarded or
popular intellectual in his day no I
can't imagine he was he's not a
respected intellectual today outside of
your pot-smoking drum circle at college
respectable conventional people of
Marx's day would have laughed at the
idea that his ideas could remake the
world yet just a few decades later they
did his writings became the Keystone for
some of the most important ideological
movements of the 20th century but Marx
was like a brilliant doctor in the early
days of Medicine he could recognize the
nature of the disease although he had no
idea how to go about curing it yes Karl
Marx was central to some of the biggest
ideological revolutions of the century
here they are
yes that one was very good oh I like
that one dude
at this point in history we should all
be Marxists in a sense of agreeing with
his diagnosis of our troubles but we
need to go out and find the cures that
really will work and this is how it ends
we should all be Marxists demanding
conformity in place of intellectual
diversity and telling us exactly how to
think well how Marxist of you if you
like this video subscribe by hitting my
face or the button that says subscriber
watch one of these videos playing in a
box next to me if you didn't like this
video you're going to have to pay me
anyway that's how communism works